Hi, I'm Dave from the Burp Scanner development team and today I'm going to talk a little bit
about insertion points in Burp Scanner. So insertion points have always been a source
of confusion for our users because it's not always been clear within a request what is Burp Scanner
targeting and what is the status of the insertion points that are being scanned.
And one of the reasons for this is that Burp Scanner hasn't always been the most visible in
terms of what is going on under the hood. In older releases of Burp Suite such as the one I have here
you could only ever see a count of the insertion points that were present in any given request.
You couldn't click on the request and see what the insertion points were and actually the insertion
point count itself was only populated when the item started being actively scanned. So for these
requests that haven't yet started you didn't get a count of the insertion points. You couldn't see
what was still to come. In Burp Suite 2020 4.1 we introduced the insertion point panel to help show
what parts of a request are being attacked by Burp Scanner and in particular what the status of those
insertion points are. So in Burp Suite 2020 4.1 you can see that the insertion point count is populated for
all of the items and every time you click on an item you have the option of either looking at the base
response or the new insertion point panel. You can also right click on a request and show insertion
points to make the panel appear if it's not already showing. And in this insertion points panel you can
see everything that Burp Scanner identified as being potentially worthy of attacking as an insertion point.
So in this request you can see we have URL parameters, we have cookie parameters, we have header parameters
and folder and file name parameters as part of the request. There is also the opportunity to see how
Burp Scanner can take insertion points from one location and put them in another location. So for
instance in this request you can see that we changed the parameter from being in the URL to being a body
parameter. Now Burp Scanner doesn't scan these types of insertion points by default but you can configure it
to do so and this was just a way of helping to surface that capability within the scanner.
Another really cool thing about the insertion point view is that when you click on the insertion points
themselves you get a request highlight and the request will jump to the insertion point to show
it you in your request response viewer. So you can always see exactly what Burp Scanner is trying to
attack in the request. You also get a status icon on the right side of the panel which indicates whether
Burp has started auditing the insertion point or it should change from pending to auditing to
audited when it's complete. And you can also see that in some cases such as this cookie which is
present on Gin and Juice Shop which supports we use deliberately vulnerable web application.
This insertion point has a base value which is base64 encoded and when you base64 decode that value
it reveals that there are a few more insertion points for us to attack. My colleague Tom already did a
video about nested insertion points within Burp Scanner and how we can attack insertion points that
are within certain encodings and make sure that the payloads are in the right encoding type for the
for the server to understand. But now we actually have a visual representation where you can click through
each of the insertion points and see whether after decoding there was further insertion points underneath it.
This is a really big step forward for showing all of our users what the scanner is actually up to.
We continue to try and make updates that help understand what the scanner is doing, how the scanner
is working. So please give it a go and let us know if you have any feedback.